Уродженці Чечні дедалі частіше опиняються в полі зору німецької поліції.
Вихідці з Кавказу добре організовані і готові застосовувати силу,
йдеться в службовій доповіді Федерального відомства кримінальної поліції Німеччини,
який опинився у розпорядженні журналістів впливого німецького видАння "Шпіґель".
На думку авторів доповіді, чеченські злочинні угруповання
проявляють себе дедалі активніше в ході перерозподілу сфер впливу в кримінальному світі.
Як приклад поліцейські наводять групу "Режим 95" -
за даними Федерального відомства кримінальної поліції, це приклад підпільної структури,
яка набирає обертів і до якої залучені вихідці з Північного Кавказу.
Німецьких експертів особливо турбує брутальна жорстокість чеченців -
"готовність до застосування насильства
набагато вища середньої", йдеться в доповіді.
За прикладами далеко йти не треба.
Навесні 2016 року у Берліні в результаті підриву автомобіля
загинув ймовірний наркоторговець - сліди вели
до чеченських угруповань, стверджує поліція.
А в міському суді Берліна вже понад рік триває процес
над трьома чеченцями, які брали участь
в нападі на кафе із застосуванням вогнепальної зброї.
Цікава деталь: як стверджується в закритій доповіді,
охоронні підприємства, що перебувають під контролем чеченських угруповань,
залучалися до охорони поліцейських будівель у Німеччині,
зокрема й місць розміщення спецпризначенців.
У самому Федеральному відомстві кримінальної поліції
у відповідь на запит Deutsche Welle від коментарів відмовилися.
Представник МВС Німеччини на прес-конференції у Берліні
у відповідь на питання Deutsche Welle про чеченські клани в Німеччині
обмежився загальним коментарем:
Загалом, я можу сказати вам, що органи безпеки -
незалежно від походження злочинців,
і це особливо стосується організованої злочинності -
дуже щільно співпрацюють і прагнуть не просто знайти
і визначити ці структури, а й припинити їхню діяльність.
Одночасно з публікацією "Шпіґеля" поліція провела
масштабну операцію в гуртожитку для претендентів на статус
біженця в місті Бранденбург на Гафелі  -
60 кілометрів на захід від Берліна -
у межах розслідування серії розбійних нападів,
скоєних вихідцями з Чечні.
Під час операції затримали п'ятеро чеченців, всі вони молодші 20 років.
Навесні цього року міністр внутрішніх справ федеральної землі Бранденбург
в інтерв'ю Deutsche Welle заявив про необхідність інтеграції чеченських біженців.
Нам потрібно і те, і інше.
Потрібна посилена інтеграція, хоча тут я мушу зауважити,
що інтегруватися зможе тільки той, хто цього хоче.
І, звичайно, потрібна поліція.
Причому не тільки для покарань, а й для профілактики.
Тому що на Північному Кавказі поліцію сприймають як інструмент,
спрямований проти громадян.
Нам же треба довести, що наша поліція працює заради людей.
Що вона захищає громадян і що їм не потрібно займатися самообороною.
А це уявлення ще живе в багатьох головах.
Таке відчуття, що люди збираються разом тому,
що їм здається, що поліція не хоче
або не може їх захистити. Це життєвий досвід,
який вони принесли з собою з батьківщини.
І нам слід переконати людей в тому,
що в Німеччині поліція працює заради громадян, а не проти них.
Місто Берлін і федеральна земля Бранденбург, яка його оточує,
вважаються лідерами в Німеччині за кількістю чеченців,
які тут проживають - щонайменше сім тисяч людей.
Торік улітку у Котбусі після масової бійки між біженцями з Чечні та Афганістану
поліція затримала понад 20 чеченців -
їхні родичі у відкритому листі владі
звинуватили поліцію у порушенні прав затриманих.